since netflix has been producing Marvel
series fans have seen some of their
favorite ground level heroes come to
life like daredevil jessica jones and
luke cage however many have been
wondering where's Iron Fist it's been
suggested the game of thrones active in
Jones maybe playing Iron Fist I'm Lucy
with a quick Netflix news update Finn
Jones plays ser Loras Tyrell on Game of
Thrones and he's going to take on the
role of Danny R and as the martial arts
master in the fourth marvel / netflix
collaboration at least thus according to
a report by Entertainment Weekly neither
Marvel nor Netflix have confirmed the
casting news at this time but in
addition to appearing in his own series
there's a good chance that iron fist
will also appear on the Luke Cage
Netflix series as well considering that
the two characters are close friends and
partners in the comics iron fist first
appeared in 1974 in Marvel premiere 15
the character is a martial arts master
who can also include some supernatural
elements to his fighting style he's also
known for being a member of the team
Heroes for Hire with his friend Luke
Cage so what do you make of the casting
let me know in the comments below or
come by me on Twitter I'm at Lucy James
games for more hell's kitchen antics
keep it gamespot